hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Minecraft I am gonna
get the hell out of these tunnels I'm
gonna leave I shouldn't be here
I don't want to be here so I'm gonna
gather up everything I have and I'm
going to leave I tried to get iron too
soon it was more than I needed
I reached too far I flew into the Sun I
burned up and died so I'm going to get
out of Dodge with my horse Wow is it
raining
oh hello iron one thank you that's
really all I wanted I didn't want more
than one I'm don't want to be greedy
here oh my god
Wow I know this isn't mind-blowing for
you guys but I'm just like oh that's
just like I remember a time when there
wasn't weather in Minecraft I believe
that was rain last time I played this is
very nice if I had crops they'd be
watered right now but I don't because I
don't have anything because I'm a loser
whatever oh it's snowing here this one
pocket it's snowing that's delightful
alright cool anyway so what I'm doing is
I'm going to stop getting ahead of
myself and I'm going to start with the
material off with which I know which is
wood which is Buddhist wood wood wood
but before I find wood I'm gonna get out
of this like valley in this the linnaeus
area of the valley hey what are you
doing here alright is it night again oh
wait no it can't be Night Out I'm not
ready for it to be night I have things I
need to do I have things new recipes
unlocked yay okay hi squid alright so
the rain really threw off my plan but
I'm not 100% sure why I don't even know
if I had a plan to begin with ooh this
is nice you know what this is fine right
here right here is where I'll start this
is my beginning I know I'm not doing
this with an axe I'll get to it in a
second this is where the new beginning
of markiplier begins this is where my
story starts it's range really loud why
didn't that make that out of stone I'm
an idiot god I'm so stupid so loud wait
I can't think gonna make some coal we're
gonna make some porches I got there
eventually guys don't worry I did it
okay and then we're gonna make stone
tools because I'm as good as a caveman
we all know this there we go now we're
better off I can't see anything
oh oh I spy with my little eye something
that is great and it's floaty I need to
build a basic house it doesn't have to
be a lot it's humble beginnings a lot of
this game is going to be about humble
beginnings these I am humble and I am at
the beginning therefore I am starting at
the humble beginnings everything about
me
is so incredibly humble I am the most
humble in the world please don't kill me
Stone Armour can I wear the horse armor
wow this game is much harder than I
remember oh babe in the woods have mercy
on me I am very bad all right I must
stop being an idiot starting officially
now what am i building I have no idea
I'm gonna build a door yes a spruce door
hey hey no no no no no no no no no no
there's like a I saw it but this like a
cave I'm gonna just put a door right
there and I'm gonna hole up in here and
you ain't gonna get nothing to nobody
you understand me
get out of here you get out of here I
ain't bothering nobody nobody gonna
bother me okay that's
just wanted a Minecraft okay you know
what screw it screw it screw the horse
armor screw everything that I had screw
all of it I don't need it I don't need
it cuz I'm beginning to think that I'm
gonna die a lot for some reason so I
should just start in the plains that's
where it put me that's where I start
that's where I belong this heifers this
chickens
those creepers there's spiders but but
but big but I will feel safe maybe I
could go up into the mountains is like
trees and mountains I might be able to
go up into the mountains yeah yeah I'm
fine I know I'm back at the beginning
again but just bear with me it's gonna
it's gonna be a bumpy ride I don't
remember if like apples do fall from
these trees sometimes that used to be a
thing maybe I could get some food sire
please whatever benevolent deity is
controlling my fate in this universe
please I could use some apples if that
is a thing that is possible oh my god I
just know God you do not please I please
horse please l fell for you
[Applause]
just peacefully live that's all is that
so hard is that so hard oh man I made
the right call sticking close to host
top I'm going to kill you
you are done dead skeleton you're dead
you are dead dead what's war you think
you are live you're dead I'm fine I'm
good I can see clearly now the rain is
gone
I can see all obstacles in my way
starting to lose it and I can't lose it
that's what I can't do I need to stay
calm and collected because panic will
serve no one but the enemy the enemy
wants me to panic the enemy wants me to
struggle and die I will not thank you
this is clearly a sign that things are
gonna turn around I am meant to be here
this is where I should be
this is where I belong I am glad to be
here in this place of bounty and plenty
it was my foolish mistake for going far
away from the starting zone of course I
would die I flew too far from the nest
who was too soon my baby wings weren't
able to stretch out and take flight
I fell calamitous Lee to the ground I
slammed in and I died now I have iron
wooden pickaxe really doesn't cut it for
this I'm got it I'm going to make it
stone as it was foretold and as I shall
do I shall make stone - I don't have
stone realize this now my error but it's
okay
it is alright Babu
father Dib ooh yes and then bothered yes
yes
and then Bob I don't have a bird uber
uber a little bit a little bit a little
bit so all I have to do is make sure yes
rich yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes now
this is what the prophecy is foretold
okay now all I have to do is build a
base that I can put a door and some
torches around as soon as I have that
I've got the goods all right so I've got
the torches I've got the iron I've got
the cobblestone I'm gonna make a furnace
we're gonna be in business we're gonna
be in business baby I'm actually gonna
just for the sake of organization I'm
gonna put this here I'm gonna put this
nope
there we go put the thing in there but
that in there and boom we're cooking
with tall anyway now I need to find some
food which may means squid delicious
sweet delicious squid sweet tasty
delicious squid yes partner ink all you
want you ain't gonna live delicious ink
sack that's not food is it does a horse
give meat I'd feel bad killing a horse I
guess again I guess I shouldn't it's all
for my survival I'll get one of these
cows it half earned this and ever news
if I make a bucket I can I can milk them
I can milk you fun look cow I don't have
to kill a cow and then I keep getting
more milk I just have to use the iron
that I got to make a bucket and that's
not the way it was just gonna be a dingo
one
all right good good good good good good
good good good good good good good
excellent excellent this is great this
is excellent this is good and now I can
use this Iren here to make a a a bucket
I forget how that's not a bucket that's
a cauldron how do I make a bucket bucket
bucket bucket bucket bucket bucket Thank
You recipe book you are incredible
smoker I can make a smoker interesting
smoker yes yes
I need shears I know I need shears
because I'm gonna need to make a bed
only got so much time I know but I need
to make a bed at some point in the
future and I might as well make this and
this iron tools baby and now that I have
this bucket I can go get the milk I can
milk that cow it's otters won't know
what touched them that sounds so wrong
am AI milk you that's still so strange
to me yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes may I milk you delicious milk ma'am
from your man's man that still sounds
very very unpleasant I am also very
hungry did I not get enough milk can I
have more milk please
apparently that didn't do the job milk
in my mouth milk my mouth not doing I'm
milking you how much I'm thinking so
much milk
I've milk to capacity I can't sprint I'm
so hungry I don't want to kill him oh I
don't want to you but it's a matter of
survival but these things are here and
they're so beneficial but it's a matter
of survival how did I get food before
chickens
kill the chickens who cares kill them
dead but I don't know why milk hasn't
given me any as sustenance I drink milk
is a boy in Mama now my bones are dense
as a desert as
as the Hoover Dam Oh fish fish fish fish
oh never fished like this before you
know what I think it's okay desperate
times and all I saw oh no no no no son
don't go down no no no no no it's on you
talk about the hole son please please
I'm not ready I'll eat the raw fish oh
my god that's not enough son please wait
no son son
it's son give me wheat wait wait please
I'm slurping straight from the cow bubut
no give me no meat Mars I just need to
find my home I need to shelter up in a
hole and I need to put a door on it I
need to make a door first eyes down here
I think is my but it's fine it's fine
this is this will be my hole this is my
hole it was meant for me this is my hole
god what a pathetic haul stupid fool
alright here's my hole guys that's my
hole no one going my hole it's meant for
me and me alone my my hole my home
humble beginnings everybody is humble
beginnings humble beginnings that's what
it is it's just we're starting at the
bottom and we will be at the top we will
be at the top we will I rest assured
because I know how to fish I'm out of
fish you jump into a river with a sword
and you start hacking as fast and
furiously as possible
take this stick my sword new do you
think you can survive these fish thought
they could live peacefully in the river
little did they know that the markiplier
had set up nearby
doom in the shape of a sword I need to
get rid of these how do I make a box box
I made a bar I did it guys guys I did it
I'm done did BAM done let me make two
hours I'm going crazy I'll make two
boxes yeah I'll make two don't they
stretch together when you make two
busses oh my god they do four that's the
good stuff this is the excellent stuff
alright so there's enough being an idiot
let me eat my cook salmon
food in my tum tum tum that was
delicious and I wish I had my armor I
would tame you I would tame you so fast
you wouldn't even understand the word
tame when it comes to your brain you
wouldn't even know anyway so what am I
do now is what are you what are you what
are you granted the hell is granite
excuse me I've never heard of granite
this is new there's some Tekkit crap
gravel alright so what I'm going to do
is I'm making this gonna be my mind my
mind my shaft with which I'm going to
get and then I will find Dimond and then
I will be rich and then the game will be
over because when you find diamond
that's the end of it and nothing else
will come about but come come of it
nothing will come between me and my
diamonds alright super speed time-lapse
of whatever the hell I'm doing go
[Music]
what did I just hear I'm playing that
again for me lik seein now play it
backwards now play it in slow motion but
distorted now overlay it with siren
heads siren call oh my god siren head is
in Minecraft
did they have they made a siren ed mod
for Minecraft I bet they have I bet that
exists I bet that's the thing and I bet
it's I bet is horrible
ooh found something here we go we have
made it to some kind of a bottom natural
chasm Yusei good thing I found coal I
was running low oh is that a creeper I
think I see a creeper over there
Oh creeper no creepy creeper no creeping
creeper no creeping creeper no creepy
yeah whatever I already there we go
stupid oh oh I didn't bring any wah
wah okay but I can fill it in right if I
remember correctly I can fill this in
and it'll be fine
yeah yeah easy peasy z GG Pazuzu
get you oh is a needy piggy would you
need a PC I don't trust any of that
there we go that's what I thought blah
blahdy blah they sure made it global up
a little more oh yes yes yes baby yes I
suppose I could bring up a bucket of
lava I don't know why
needed why do I need a bucket of lava or
I can put it in a furnace can I can I
yes-no yes-no do I dare am i ballsy
enough yes yes I am had to do some
introspection in there had to look deep
within my soul had to look deep within
my part but I have determined that I am
indeed ballsy enough
not many dare to look so deep into their
own heart and soul lexy and replace
everything I just said was something
family-friendly okay we're fine all
right let's get out of here we got some
goods we get some ayran wash or wish I
had Auto jump
thunk thunk thunk-thunk I'm alive boom
all right let's do this
and let's do that yeah yeah baby that's
pretty cool all right so we got some
diorite I don't know what the diorite is
fur always show craftable yeah that'd be
nice dye right granite wall granite
polished granite block of iron
why is a smithing table what's a
smithing table
what are you I can't even what do you do
I really honestly have no idea I'm
clueless but it's starting to get dark I
might need to go to bed but I'm starting
to feel a little braver starting to feel
like maybe the little world ain't so
scary and also I need to get a farm
going yeah I need to start getting a
farm going cuz I got a baked bread I
gotta get this bread if I don't have
this bread ain't gonna go nowhere much
wheat I got 13 yes a good number al oh
yeah I think I can work with that all
right I have dirt so I'm gonna make my
dirt farm over in here this will be a
good dirt farming area I'll expand it
little by little I think I remember the
basic principles of farming you put a
seed in the ground and then you put
water around it and then you've got
yourselves a farm doesn't like some good
old night farming
I am nobody gonna startle me none I'm
unstart Allah Ville sploosh
wait what your recipe book what do I
have boiled water what recipe what an
incredible recipe he's a genius he's a
genius unlike any other what did I get I
got nothing I got a whole lot of going a
little bit of diddly that's what I got
what a useless pile of poopy sploosh
sploosh sploosh good thing the waters
unlimited wait it didn't seem to be slip
it seems like maybe there was a limit
hey wait hang on what what's going on
here is it a liminal water what oh stop
stop stop stop stop stop
you're being ridiculous I've made
whirlpools it's just it's gonna bug me
if these aren't fully splooshed up so I
got a solution to maximum explosion dude
all right so see I'm not an expert in
how physics works but I went to
engineering school and I think that this
ain't logical something tells me
something right there some tells me some
subs a little off its yeah whatever I
can't I couldn't place my finger upon it
so strange mysteries of the universe and
home oh well I guess I'll never know
anyway I need a ho-ho please thank you
Oh baby I have a ho cool what are you
doing up there what are you two doing
over there no no no no yeah drown stupid
you idiot oh I think I think about oh oh
okay yeah yeah yeah chase you the water
I don't care oh you dare now
that's my father's well I thought that's
what I thought that's why I thought
that's why I thought that hey get away
from me how weird you come from these
guys kind of suck no creeper incoming no
no please please please tell me there's
no elves on your bike okay so we got
nice it's already starting to grow I am
amazing I'm the best there ever was so
this will do for now that creeper still
alive I don't like that I forgot they
don't go away in this Sun but anyway
thank you everybody so much for watching
this is Minecraft in case you didn't
know in case you couldn't tell by my
horrible place thank you everybody so
much for watching remember you can go to
cloak brand calm that's CL Oh a KBRA
and.com link is right there in the
description to check out the new cloak
minecraft collab collection lots of cool
stuff over 30 designs here's some of
them check them out for yourself
link in the description thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]